ich hatte ja in der schule waren nicht
so gut ich bin ein bisschen nervös
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen heute mal wieder
chemie in der küche und ich habe mir für
sterne geholt das ist florian florian
ist ein kollege und er macht das format
hochkant genau hochkant ist und news und
reportagen auch snapshot und instagram
wie verändern sich deutschland und
europa was hab schon wieder eingerichtet
und ist streaming ist wirklich richtig
illegal
bei opel gibt es news reportagen und
hintergründe und dazu persönlich
einblicke in meinen leben als ob also
wenn es ein bisschen interessiert was in
der welt los ist
ich erzähle ich euch auch hochkant endet
einfach hochkant auf cnet und ins exil
floh waren die leute hier weil du gesagt
hast wir machen pulver aus suckow aus
strich und das will ich mir nicht
entgehen lassen extreme hast du schon
mal gehört dass ein bisschen vorgehen so
protein pulver das hier
ist ein zucker der eine zucker wenn man
jetzt hier einfach diesen strich durch
zeichnete und die klammer
das ist ich muss nochmal fordern diese
eine zucker werde traubenzucker oder so
im werk lammers kommt genau also es gibt
einfach zweifach zucker zum beispiel
unsere haushaltszucker ist ein zweifach
zucker saccharose
und wenn man die jetzt ganz viele
aneinander hängt in der kette dann haben
wir ein bulli sache hielt also profi
mehrfachzucker oder auch kohlenhydrate
zucker ist erst mal süß und zweitens ist
es wasserlöslich richtig ja stärke kann
ich nicht mehr im wasser lösen was hier
fürs wasser wichtig ist sind diese
gruppen die verstehen sich gut mit
wasser das sagen auch tatsächlich so man
sagt hydrogel das heißt so viel wie
wasser liebend im winter viele gruppen
da sind löst sich das im wasser problem
ist was passiert jetzt wenn man das
immer länger macht also gucken wir mal
hier
wenn das jetzt nur ein zuckerwürfel
traubenzucker hätten wir ein zwei drei
vier fünf gruppen der ring ist aber wir
sagen er hydro funk lassen alles
kohlenstoffatome und die verstehen sich
eben nicht so gut mit rasseln wenn wir
jetzt allein schon aus 12 machen das
wäre dann maltose dann haben wir zwei
dinge aber dann haben wir nicht die
doppelte anzahl von noah guckt nicht
zehn sondern nur acht was werden wir
haben hier in der klammer 35 x 10.6 und
dann zwar am ende das heißt das
verhältnis von hydro von ring zur gruppe
mit immer größer das heißt die länger
als die kette mache irgendwann
überwiegen die hydrophoben eigenschaften
und da ist es irgendwann nicht mehr im
wasser
maltodextrin ist jetzt zwischen zwischen
glukose und stärke irgendwo in der mitte
das ist jetzt nur so ein bisschen süß
oder es gar nicht
diesmal zu setzen wissen sie das
bisschen süß mal extreme ist immerhin so
hydrophob das ist head und öl absorbiert
und irgendwie benutzt man dass zb um
olivenöl powder zu machen um
irgendwelche fettigen flüssigkeiten in
pulver zu überführen
diese smart das ganze fett und ihrer
hohen damit erst mal auf und verschließt
sie mehr oder weniger aber sobald das
pulver dann in den mund kommt löst es
sich ja in wasser auf und selbst sofort
diese ganzen aromen und das pat fry und
das wären jetzt heute versuchen mir
läuft schon das wasser im mund zusammen
also ich habe hier ungefähr 240 grad
regen gemischt mit schokocreme und noch
butter also auch noch nicht hat ich habe
das gerade ein gemisch und hat das
gefühl dass nicht genug die mutter und
hier herzlich
ich glaube das sind 160 gramm mal zu den
extremen alles was er machen muss ist
das zum beispiel in einen mixer zu geben
ist richtig gut physikalisch zu
malträtieren mit langsamer durch jede
löffel ach es ist egal
das ist die gute alte funk maschine
ja also ihr wisst ihr werden sehr viele
vor allem viele rosen
[Musik]
also wird seit aus dass auch dass beides
zusammen gemischt ist richtig was
anderes ist jetzt nicht ich habe ja dass
man braucht mehr fett aber das ist
leider hatte ich glaube ich so weit und
das gegenteil von dem machen was ich
denke du bist ich würde ja viel sagen
wir brauchen mehr pulver
was wir versuchen es nicht geklappt lage
gewesen die richtigen musikalischen
bearbeitung passiert noch mal was ganz
anderes ich glaube ich bin für erklärt
werden sonst für das große zeug also
folglich auch eine neue maschine
ich glaube das ist es und so schön braun
halle flow also passt auf ich bin gerade
am schneiden des videos ich bin auch
schon fast fertig und die aufnahme
stoppt in dem moment wo wird die löffel
in die hand nehmen - zu probieren
die zeit war einfach drüber das gute ist
dass die zuschauer nicht so viel
verpasst haben
ja also hatte eigentlich nichts damit zu
tun dass das pulver im mund schlagartig
zerfließt schmilzt und dann irgendeine
geschmacks explosion auslöst das ist
überhaupt nicht passiert leute verpasst
was das jetzt besser nuss nougat creme
oder nuss nougat creme pulver viel
besser wir haben einfach ein ganzes glas
nussnougatcreme verschleudert ach so das
ist noch die zweite gute nachricht die
küchenmaschine er geht wieder
erst wenn wir die packungen maltodextrin
verlosen
ja und hoffentlich viel besser als wir
das ist tatsächlich die packung die
fluren ich benutzt haben das heißt sie
ist angebrochen aber das meiste von
diesem kino maltodextrin ist noch drin
wenn ihr bock habt euch da selber
auszuprobieren schreibt in die
kommentare
dass ihr das haben möchtet und warum und
der kommentar mit der besten antwort
kriegt das zugeschickte alle weiteren
infos in der infobox in dem bei snap
chat oder instagram seid dann schaut man
noch flow von hochkant ich bin übrigens
auch auf instagram leute ihr folgendes
passieren ganz viele tolle dinge die ihr
alle verpasst spitzelei zivis bescheid
schön schlau bleibt sicher